okay yeah hi guys I'm back and I'm gonna
open them for mail cuz remember this I
got the last one haha
people think that I have a baby when I
walk around with this but I used to go
pick up mail today yay so I'm gonna open
it in front of you because this is a
mail log and uh that's just gonna happen
yeah sorry if the audio is screwy I have
a fan on underneath my desk that's
blowing straight up into my couch to
keep me at a cool temperature so let's
get right into it there's a lot of
letters so I apologize if I go really
fast I just want to try and get through
all of them and it's gonna be long no
matter what so let's start with the
postcard from Alaskan wild flowers oh
they look so wild in Alaska but they
also look at the kabhi New Jersey New
Jersey sometimes they have these on the
UM expressway to make it seem less dirty
and scummy okay cool Tim saw this
postcard and thought I'll send that
[ __ ] some Alaskan Wallflower [ __ ]
love Alaska more flowers high grades
higher huggers it's true I love them
because they're um they're not tamed and
it's from I don't know whether this
they'll Nolan Nolan Nolan something and
Nolan kind I think Thank You Nolan you
are so kind
oh my gosh okay this is from Oh mass
just mass that's all it says let's see
oh is this Biff that's here okay Shh all
right let's see what's in here what's in
here oh great surely recent fun to watch
my favorite part is when you can't think
of something to say hey I did it for you
huh oh no no no no no next time maybe
this will help we are best friends it's
official oh my god she sent me or he/she
mark Erin to manhunts Boyd sent me half
of a BFF bracelet friends forever charm
well yeah we this makes it official
whether I wanted it or not I got it
thank you so much that's so sweet
let's see Oh is this from haha oh I
gotta cover up the addresses noob user
look at that
sorry guys for doing your addresses out
my bad
I like this envelope though it looks
like it might have been from recycled
paper huh
you imagine what a world thank you oh
you're welcome
but what for all the laughs from Drew
this is like simple design all for you I
love this this is so simple so nice and
I like the shape it's oblong ish what I
don't know how to describe things let's
see by airmail oh man Royal Mail pardon
me oh my gosh this is all taped up and
wrinkly this is like a an old man in a
psychiatric ward taped it's wrinkly get
it up that's a stretch oh my gosh
there's something wrapped up and then
there's a litter it's so sweet it's
already you've really nice handwriting
instantly hi grace I got a few you've
got appeal box yeah and look I sent you
something here it is wowee oh and you
have sheeps drawn on here oh my gosh and
then you have your little families in a
little Bloody Mary I love them and this
is a really long letter and I will read
it later apologize for not reading y'all
camera but come on but thank you for
this and now I'm going to open this
which is probably reference to the
letter if I read it but I'm not reading
it to later when the cameras off oh this
is a really nice piece of paper that you
wrap this said thank you oh my gosh what
is this some drugs good that would be
bad I think it's a where something Oh
broken oh no it's broken oh no it's
broken it's all broken you send me a
necklace and the charm broke oh my gosh
it's not your fault
that's unless you did send it broken
maybe you did send it broken
um I know but it's really I'm sure would
have been like really beautiful and cute
and thank you for this I'm sorry that it
broke if it wasn't supposed to but it's
pretty look it so nice um I don't know
what to say like that other person
wishes coming true right knocks they
don't have to say thank you though for
this Benjamin but the post office of
bridge some real [ __ ] in a [ __ ] I'm
hot sorry I'm sweating already got this
fan up in me get in me fan Thank You
Bailey Warren whoo from Bothell
Washington I thought the said brothel
Washington thank God it didn't what's
going on here like man handling all of
these envelopes oh we need the PO
you have amazing handwriting look at
that that looks like fun it looks like
effing font
oh this is so sweet you put a ticker
sticker on there oh I have three words
for you you are hilarious oh my gosh
those are really nice three words thank
you for that I
you can drink families anytime oh thank
you your name is Bailey water that's the
sweetest thing I will read this um after
the cameras off but thank you so much to
us litter it's so sweet of you
I'm sort of losing my voice a little but
if you couldn't tell holy crap look at
that then it's crazy oh my god who did
this Audrey Rome's you what a name from
California and your your address thing
has a cat on it that's cool oh my gosh
you put so much time into that that is
crazy
something popped up on my computer and
I'm saying things out loud okay oh I've
already ruined the symbol of [ __ ] how do
I not ruin it artists transient sorry
yeah no I'm keeping it preserving it see
oh colors like holy crap this page is
going on here
ah you make me laugh we made fun funny
brownies good Audrey oh this is the
front of the letter oh man
two letters and someone drew someone
dying
oh that's rolling on the floor laughing
huh thank god they're not a dead person
Wow I will read this later from Ali and
og Thank You girls is it the sweetest
things they're so colorful there's so
much how do I get this back together
it's like huh I might be there we go
puzzles usually girls are better at
puzzles from chellb
what if funny name this is a funny name
she'll be pulling a heart some little
things the little details that are like
the truth muffin things what whoo this
looks interesting
whoa bubble letters I used to practice
bubble etics greetings from Iowa Iowa
where's that that's like near Indiana
middle of the United States something
like that cool how is it there awesome
that sounds nice from Shelby me May what
a damn Oh you drew Princess Grace
Princess Grace that is so you are more
beautiful in real life
oh wait did I meet you I think I met you
somewhere what she'll bow to six on
Twitter thank you maybe I met you I feel
like your name sounds really familiar I
meet you at VidCon haha this is funny
this girl sucks justin hays that's great
huh what is the price thank you so much
for this that's so sweet of you
laughs you know this would be a funny
drinking game video dude took a shot
every time I said thank you honey you'd
be dead huh look at it's called Stowers
that's so cool this is from Danielle her
poor back oh that's so fun what
nationality is that added some extra
stamps just to make sure at least they
are awesome oh you are already awesome
tell me stamps oh you put three stamps
arms are very pretty thank you for that
oh oh
open I'm ruining this you
stars but nothing in life laughs right
what this oh you put bracelets in there
that's tight and I'll snap oh man I get
it because they're rubber bands puns
I love puns except that's tight Kabhi a
little bit misconstrued maybe who knows
thank you for these I put them on right
now are these bracelets are they just
supposed to be rubber bands are they
supposed to be person rubber bands but
with a fence Thank You blue and white
that was my high school colors so thank
you how did you know what the crap is
this it's a fish pond stationary ma'am
stationary these days hello grace how's
it going I thought I would send you this
will paper sack for my work because I'm
an [ __ ] ha ha no your [ __ ]
what no I meant to say that your work is
really nice stationary oh and you're
from Michigan so it's take that goes
like this that's so fun very cool thank
you so much for the bracelet that just
like the coolest thing in the world
thank you I got it get a container to
put all the mail in oh this has some
weight to it oh man oh my own it's taped
up so well this is from Shelby graves
Shelby you did such a great job of tip
no that didn't work as a pun hello from
the bottom ok it's a little sandwich
that looks like it just says lettuce on
it a little lettuce sandwich a little
stack of pancakes Oh are these erasers
who knows I'm gonna try and use them for
regardless this is so cool
thank you nom nom nom just kidding you
know oh it's a picture of Harry and
Hermione with Dumbledore look at them
the back of their heads are so
attractive oh it's a bunch of pic
of Harry Potter scenes what are these
tattoos no they're not tattoos that
would be ludicrous Ludacris remember
that rapper I love dearly grace oh and
you drew I think these are supposed to
be me I look so skinny thank you that's
so nice where is the other one oh you
have another a letter with a what's a
picture it's a bear and a squirrel this
is awesome and the pears on a helicopter
this is some Bowie and the squirrels
riding a guitar this is social
commentary right this is something about
life oh man hi grace hi
dear he's hot you were definitely my
favorite youtuber I stamp until 4:00
a.m. I'm watching your videos most
nights get some sleep it's good for your
body but thank you that's so nice oh oh
hey I put her stickers they're stickers
thank you so much Shelby this is awesome
I will read this letter I promise okay
what's where we got 16 black Oh why my
saying is I don't be day when they ever
love that's why sorry
welcome to drunk downtown
dumb dumb town never mind two of the
Daily Grace hostess oh so cute
oh my goodness hi my name is Charlie
Schmitz I'm 12 years old almost 13 on
August 11th well happy early birthday to
you Charlie Schmidt's I go to way I'm
not guys they were almost we could go to
but thank you this is just a regular
family - oh please it's more than that
so thanks for being here and being
helpful in your videos for others oh you
are so sweet charlie a girl thanks
because I was thinking that you were a
boy huh PS you should do more of daily
great vice oh maybe I will thanks
charlie it's a fairly sweet of you what
an adorable little girl now let's go to
Sydney Rosa from Little Rock Arkansas
Bill Clinton is from Little Rock looks
like the only fact I know about any
president ever woo what's that foot
please
I like it it's so simple your
handwriting is very nice hello I can't
repress your finish for the first time
the other day new user calm and I wanted
I'm such a dick in his lab sorry I wanna
thank you for putting a smile on my face
every day oh and grace is your middle
name that's so cool
thanks Disney this is like the sweetest
little thing you guys are just like a
barrel of monkeys that are covered in
sugar you know what I mean oh my thighs
are sweating but we got more letters
let's do more them oh here's a postcard
huh
no one thinks you're funny this is
already awesome I can already tell just
kidding
oh Anthony from Ithaca New York you got
me my self-esteem started to go so thank
you for making it a joke this is
actually really great no one thinks
you're funny and it's a puppy inside a
boot and the poop looks like it's made
out of denim which is like an added
bonus I love your show it brightens up
the day for me I hope you continue to
inspire and entertain us for years to
come you are so nice and you put a bunch
of Hello Kitty stickers on there thank
you and for me this is such a sweet
postcard where did you get this by the
way because I would like to purchase
some for my own use thank you
oh let's see Lesley Yuri us from Downey
California did you guys need vent dryer
sheets or laundry detention haha
you know Downey wrinkle release it's
good stuff
Oh grace helbig oh that's my name and
you wrote it so nicely
you guys have like whoa oh my god
it's penis confetti you make penis
confetti that's amazing
there's so many little dicks these are
I'm glad um you spent the time to cut
out all these little dicks I wonder if
your parents wondered what you were
doing it doesn't matter cuz this is
awesome thank you
oh man
this is a very long letter you may look
like the greatest penmanship and also
the greatest collection of colored pens
I've ever seen this is a really long
letter so I'm gonna read it later thank
you so so much Lesley yes this is so
great oh this is so great my voice is
sounding like an ass a little bit so I
apologize
what do we got Lucinda whoo spicy
oh you're from Brooklyn dang girl
hop skip and a jump maybe I don't know
you're sweating
I think flowing oh nice paper stock
already I like it oh whoa hey grace
how's it going i watch your videos every
morning I tried to step super late to
watch them but I've summer school in the
morning girl you do your thing
don't worry about watching them right
away they'll be there this letter was
written with my blood Oh cute Daily
Grace Brooklyn wow look at all these did
you do these in summer school
I bet you did or just what you did
during regular school that you hadn't
take summer school for just kidding
these are crazy faces look at them these
are like this is like basically what's
going on in my brain every single time I
make a vlog especially dry like mudkips
that's forever that is mmm I don't know
I may be but also probably not who knows
thank you so much for that that was
really super sweet I hope that you like
Brooklyn I don't know why I said that
but sure I'll say it Kylee Crocs
Kylie cracks oh don't show that I dress
face have you learned nothing
oh I have a feeling I know what this
might be
let's see it's a crawl
Oh oh my god I know who you are dear
grace hi you're reading a croc I'm not
an artist nor sad lead if I owned any
Crocs I just had to wing the drawing
side from Bob RT all the time with Crocs
but kind of a big part of my life though
this girl writes on everything that I do
the word Crocs don't think it's gonna
notice I see it oh I see it I see it but
this is super impressive you made a croc
out of nothing and it's got a little a
little thing for your foot Oh minutes
thank you so much for this keep doing
what you do and I hope for the best for
you from Kylie Crocs Thank You Kylie
Crocs there I said it I finally set the
word Crocs how you feel about it
good satisfied now what now what do you
do thank you for this this is really
sweet of you okay okay oh that air force
a nice get on me ah there it is oh my
goodness
okay let's we got here Sabina and Ivana
terraza from Puerto Rico holy crap holy
crap
what'd you send me so there before we go
you crazies you crazy what's in here oh
you taste it so well phone I just broke
the entire envelope so their photo must
be sad to be an envelope whoa hello
grace we found this on our airplane to
Canada for vacation I thought you might
want to review it just like you did with
the Victoria's Secret catalog they sent
me a SkyMall
SkyMall like the greatest catalog of all
time if you've never flown in a plane it
is awesome they have ridiculous things
and they have about like literally
10,000 this is a fun look 10,000
products for your dog so you can get
anything you want the seat dose from
Puerto Rico thank you so much for this
SkyMall I will read this and I will
probably do something with it who knows
okay let's see and peace sir oh stop
showing their address self Oh what is
this your
or reamed out California that sounds
like Ortega which reminds me that I'm
hungry yeah uh oh my gosh
what is this it's an eland wrapping
paper I really love it whatever it is I
already love it oh my gosh what dear
grace you were amazing you never fell to
make me laugh and everyone I've shown
your video so thank you that is so so
nice she's got an awesome website and
Pistor tumblr.com oh my god she's
selling one-of-a-kind hand-painted
shirts with awesome people's faces on it
like mine shirt when they happen face on
me wearing my own face this is I what
what did you do and then there's a mr.
grace you are awesome message inside
this is in say my teeth are so white
thank you that's so generous this is I
don't I can't what the crap holy where'd
you let her go where did you let her go
oh oh go to her website and Pistor a nnp
IST ER tumblr calm and check out her
painted shirts holy f e FV f and then
she's got a picture of herself wearing
one oh my god what a nice woman thank
you so much for that holy crap my brain
just just be very careful when I washed
it
this is I don't know whoa whoa thank you
I need to gather myself for a second
because I'm having a little bit of
reasonable thank you so much this is
insane that you did this holy holy holy
Lord Lord of Honor with that that's
coming into my brain thank you so much
for this this is insane wowie Zowie okay
there's one last thing to open and that
uh it's pretty obvious white save for
last so let's open this this is from an
n-channel pan of Fairfax Virginia
thank you already uh how am I gonna do
this my legs are so sweaty okay okay I
don't even know how to do this I don't
want to break anything that's inside ah
crap Oh No all right let's see ah this
is complete wrong way to do this I don't
know what did you oh I do not want to
hurt whatever in here oh no what is this
okay scissors to grace it's a picture
skyline with the hair on it
this is so cool you guys look you guys
are in there
Oh Jax this is so cool thank you so much
that was too much too much let me read
this holy crap oh it's a dog you look at
a fish oh my god I can't take it dear
grace back in December I asked you on
Twitter if you could suggest some good
eats in New York because I was going to
visit you suggested pommes frites do you
remember well was the best ever I love
fries thank you so much wow you took
this picture
holy crap she took this picture while
she was here in New York and may she's a
photographer with a youtube channel
what's your YouTube channel youtube.com
slash abpa and photo go look at that
this food was so cool Oh Angela beep an
a beep an calm go check the depth thank
you so much this is so awesome thank you
everyone thank you so much for all of
these nice things that you you have sent
and wrote and uh oh I'm gonna have a
heart attack before I turn 26
thank you guys I hope that you have fun
watching this okay I'm gonna try and do
these once a week but we'll see thank
you so much you are the sweetest little
cherubs and a pinch in your internet
cheeks the face ones on your face bye
guys thank you